everyone's already in sighs dad tell me
who'll kill my child I work for the
government
not terrorists you used to work for them
I don't know who the bombers are don't
believe you it will tell me the names of
the Bombers strange maybe special forces
a lot of us would be safe here I
wouldn't count on it
the foreigner rigid are give me the
names of the bonus
everyone's already inside an explosion
rocked the city today 20,000 pounds for
the names of the Bombers that's not how
we do things
hello that's five days in a row now does
he want his daughter was killed in the
bombing mr. Hennessy please find out the
names of the Bombers I work for the
government not harassed you used to work
for them I don't know who the bombers
are don't believe you it's him you will
tell me the names of the Bombers the DA
on Tuesday he's trained
maybe Special Forces just wants you to
know he can get to you what is going on
thinks I know who Lord was daughter do
you somebody say a prep stick inside of
half the city looking from
for me
then you gotta live me pills oh man
running circles around a lot of us ahead
of us every step of the way open it up
[Music]
yes I do do you
you